i told myself that why should a person
be
in such a have to go through such
difficulties in order to be able to have
access to
necessity which is bread food right
nutrition a reality that hits close to
home for lutheran social services of
nevada
executive director armena mkhitaryan who
came up with the concept of digimart
a digital market that allows people to
shop online for food
using the non-profit's on-site computers
and pick it up from the food pantry
that day when i was young i was a
teenager i had to stand in line to buy
bread
and it would take me three to four hours
and i remember those winter colds
tuesday afternoon a ribbon cutting took
place for their new 3000 square
foot food pantry with a walk-in cooler
and freezer to qualify for our services
especially our digimart
you don't have to be lutheran you don't
have to have faith
you just need to have a need the idea
came about in 2016 and today's process
has cut waiting times down from a couple
of hours
to 15 minutes per person with the
pandemic in the first few weeks we had
about 400 percent
increase in the number of people we
serve so the opportunity of having
a really large facility for
food storage is really helpful those
interested can come in
sign up in the system and get started
placing and receiving their order
all in one day
and what's so neat about this concept is
that with digimart
it's based on a point system so the
healthier food items are actually worth
less point so you can stock up on more
healthier food items than
junk food that's worth more points
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now